you should be careful with your words
because when you use them you're doing
one of two things you're either creating
what's good or you're doing the opposite
I know no one who hasn't been radically
successful who isn't radically expert at
communication and that also means
they're radically expert at thought
because mostly we think in words and so
and when you write your learning to
think and when you're using the language
that you've strived to Master you are
literally generating the present and the
past out of the future in the direction
you're aiming at that's what you're
doing that's what Consciousness
does and so you want to have respect for
that you want to take your place in the
world you better learn how to use your
tongue hey it's EV carlmichael and I
make these videos because I want to wake
up and feel like today is going to
matter that I can do something special
and the way that I get that feeling is I
see people who are doing amazing things
and in watching them say amazing things
and do amazing things it makes me feel
like I can do amazing things too so I
hope that this video helps you feel like
you can do something amazing today as
well so today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Jordan
Peterson
enjoy one of the chapters of my books is
is focused on putting your house in
order it's like well how do you start
make your
bed you know I I it actually took me
quite a long time in my life before I
made my bed regularly in the morning
most of my life was put in pretty good
order but that was one thing I didn't
have in order my clo clothes in my
closet as well all that's in order not
all of it I'm cleaning out some drawers
right now
but look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look it's like okay I'm
in my room do I like this room no it
bugs me okay why well the paint's
peeling there and it's dusty there and
the carpet's dirty and that corner is
kind of ugly and the light there isn't
very good and my closed closet's a mess
so I don't even like to open it um okay
that's a lot of problems that sucks
that's a lot of opportunity pick
something and fix it something that bugs
you yeah but not too much so it the rule
is pick something you know would make
pick a problem pick a solution to it
that you know would help that you could
do that you would do so you have to
negotiate with yourself it's like well I
won't clean up this room how do you know
I've been in here for 10 years and I've
never cleaned it up it's like well
obviously that's too big a dragon for
you would you clean one
drawer find out and so imagine now you
want to be happy when you open that
drawer and you think well that's stupid
it's like is
it maybe it's your sock drawer which I
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way you're going to you're going to
open that every morning yeah so that's
like 30 seconds of your life every day
okay so that's 3 minutes a week that's
12 minutes a month that's 2 hours a year
so maybe your life is made out if you
got 16 hours a day let's figure this out
5 12 in an hour 12 in an hour 144 in 12
hours yeah let's say 200 205 minute
chunks that's your life ladies and
gentlemen Jordan Peterson did just some
math how many 5 minute chunks there are
in a day and I'm pretty sure that's
pretty accurate it's approximately right
so you got 2005 minute chunks and they
repeat a lot of them repeat mhm so if
you get every one of those right they're
trivial right who cares what my sock
drawer looks like it's fair enough man
but that's your life the things you
repeat every day yeah the mundane things
think I could get all those mundane
things right that's the game rules it's
like now all the mundane is in place now
you can play because all the mundane in
place you're going to find the meaning
in your life by
adopting by adopting maximal
responsibility right that's going to be
extremely difficult because you're so
bloody useless you can't even get your
own house in order and you're and you're
going to be called upon not only to get
your house in order but to do that well
enough so some woman can stand having
you around for more than like 15 minutes
in the back of a car and then maybe
you're going to have to do it so that
you could be a good father to a family
and a pillar of the community and that's
not just empty words it's like if you do
that nobly there'll be something to you
and then when the storms come you won't
be blown over by the first 4 foot wave
and young men think huh mean I could be
something that wasn't blown over by the
first 4 foot
wave I think oh well that's that's
that's inspiring maybe that's worth
doing a little work towards it on the
off chance it might be true and the
thing about it is it is true so it's not
that difficult once you understand it to
make a case for it it's true and it's
also true that you grow in proportion to
the weight you take on voluntarily and
it's also true that we have no idea what
the upper limit to that is right so you
know you you've met remarkable people in
your life people can do remarkable
things and there are inevitably people
who take to took on remarkable burdens
and because they did that their
development was forced by necessity they
were forced by necessity to grow beyond
what they were and who knows what the
limit to that is Strive to put yourself
in a position where you can actually
make
choices and that's actually a good
guiding principle throughout your life
you know maybe you're being oppressed at
work certainly possible and I know that
there are people who are in such dire
situations
that in some sense they're they're
trapped i' I've had lots of clients like
that right so I make allowances for the
fact that now and then you get into a
situation you just can't get out of and
that's really that's real hell forget
about that for the time
being if someone is pushing you
around you need to be able to say
no well so let's think that
through you need to know what no means
and no means if you keep doing this
something you do not like will certainly
happen to you that's what no means now
I'm not trying to make that into a
threat but it is a threat no means no
implies it implies a border well in
order to say no you have to be able to
put up the border and let's say you have
a job and you need the money and maybe
you have a family and you have no other
options you're no isn't very useful cuz
what have you got to back it up and
maybe you think well I'll stand on moral
principles and I'll quit my jobs well
great but what are you going to do for
money and how about your family right
that's a big problem and so when I had
clients in that situation that was
usually a 2-year campaign something like
that it's like well how's your resume
look and that's usually a dismal
question for people cuz it's full of
holes and they haven't updated it for 5
years and they're embarrassed about
2third of it and it's badly written
they've hidden it in some corner of
their computer where they don't even
want to look and
so haul it up let's go through it can
you fill in the gaps is there some way
that you can make yourself more
marketable so that you have options and
we could lay out a plan to see how that
might be possible maybe you're afraid of
applying for a new job because you have
to send out 50 resumés to get one bloody
interview and that's annoying and time
consuming and then maybe you don't have
any real
confidence in your interview abilities
well time to fix all that up or you stay
under the thumb of the Tyranny those are
your options and that's not a good
option because if it's if you are under
the thumb of an emerging tyranny and you
don't set yourself up to withstand it
and push back or leave for somewhere
better then it will definitely get
bigger and you will definitely get
smaller and no matter how bad it is now
it's going to be way worse in 5 years
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific specific plan of
action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there you
don't have to think except when you're
failing because the purpose of thinking
is to calculate a new trajectory and if
the trajectory you're you're pursuing is
producing the desired results then your
theory is intact
well then the question emerges which is
well how much failure is necessary to
make you think and that's actually a
moral question and that's a question of
willful blindness you know if you're
awake and alert and if you're humble in
the classic virtous sense you're always
trying to figure out where you're
insufficient and to rectify that right
in many Christian prayers that Jesus
prayer for example is a reminder that
the Orthodox uh cite that continually
chant that that continually is a
reminder that you're insufficient in
your current form and you should be
looking for what would Rectify you
that's the practice of humility and the
advantage to that practice is that you
can make micro repairs instead of
staying stubborn till the apocalypse
happens and then collapsing now in the
in the story of Moses what happens to
the Pharaoh who's a tyrant is that the
crisis emerge and then magnify right
they just get worse and worse and worse
and worse and he utter fails to respond
and the consequence of that is that his
entire Society is devastated the
firstborn are all killed and the Red Sea
floods and destroys the uh the what the
military might of the Egyptian Empire
well they say the people per perish
without Vision what is hopeful Vision
well hopeful vision is what you're
working toward you know you think well
if I could have things this way in my
family in my life in my community
that would be worthwhile I could get on
board with that well your vision of the
future that attracts you and also
provides you with security and Direction
orientation that unites you with others
that's your hopeful vision and you
perish without that and hopefully
through discussion and negotiation we
could develop something approximating a
collective hopeful Vision that we could
all be on board with like part of that
for me is well how about if we work as
hard as we can as quickly as possible to
amili absolute poverty provide
inexpensive energy as widely as possible
everywhere in the world and lift people
out of the poverty
that what would you say compels them to
adopt a cataclysmically short-term
vision of the world now you know you
might say well that's not priority
number one it's like fair enough we
could have a discussion about what
priority number one might be
but but that's for me at least an
element of what might constitute a
hopeful vision and I think it's
realistic one too given that rich people
care more about the planet they can
afford to part of the reason that people
go watch anti-heroes and villain is
because there's a part of them crying
out for the incorporation of the monster
within them which is what gives them
strength of character and self-respect
because it's impossible to respect
yourself until you grow teeth and if you
grow teeth then you realize that you're
somewhat dangerous and or maybe somewhat
seriously dangerous and then you might
be more willing to demand that you treat
yourself with respect and other people
do the same thing and so that doesn't
mean that being cruel is better than not
being cruel what it means is that being
able to be cruel and then not being
cruel is better than not being able to
be cruel because in the first case
you're nothing but weak and naive and in
the second case you're dangerous but you
have it under control and you know a lot
of martial arts concentrate on exactly
that as part of their philosophy of
training it's like we're not training
you to fight we're training you to be
peaceful and awake and avoid fights but
if you happen to have to get in one and
and I guess the philosophy also is is
that if you're competent at fighting
that actually decreases the probability
that you're going to have to fight
because when someone pushes you you'll
be able to respond with confidence and
with any luck and this is certainly the
case with bullies with any luck a
reasonable show of confidence which is
very much equivalent to a show of
dominance is going to be enough to make
the bully back off and so the strength
that you develop in your monstrousness
is actually the best guarantee of peace
there's this old story in King Arthur
where the knights go off to look for the
Holy Grail which is either the cup that
Christ drank out of at the Last Supper
or the cup into which the blood that
gushed from his side was poured when he
was crucified the stories vary but it's
it's basically a a holy object like the
Phoenix in some sense that's
representation a representation of
transformation so it's a it's an ideal
and so King Arthur's knights who sit at
a round table because they're all
roughly equal go off to find the most
valuable thing and they and where do you
look for the most valuable thing when
you don't know where it is well each of
the knights looks at the forest
surrounding the castle and enters the
forest at the point that looks darkest
to
him and that's a good thing to
understand because the gateway to wisdom
and the gateway to the development of
Personality which is exactly the same
thing is precisely through the portal
portal that you do not want to climb
through and the reason for that actually
quite technical this is a union
presupposition too is that well there's
a bunch of things about you that are
underdeveloped and a lot of those things
are because there's things you've
avoided looking at because you don't
want to look at at them and there's
parts of you you've avoided developing
because it's hard for you to develop
those parts and so it's it's by virtual
necessity that what you need is where
you don't want to look because that's
where you've kept it and so and that's
why there's you know an idiosyncratic
element of it for everyone your
particular place of Enlightenment and
terror is not going to be the same as
yours except that they're both places of
Enlightenment and Terror so they're
equivalent at one level of analysis and
and different at another so anyways back
to fiction and and and and what it does
it it
distills truth and it it it produces
characters that are Composites and the
more they become Composites the more
they approximate a mythological
character and so they become more and
more universally true and more and more
approximating religious deities but the
problem with that is they become more
and more distant from individual
experience and so with literature
there's this very tight line where you
need to make the character more than
merely human but not so much of a God
that you know one of the things that
happened to Superman in the 1980s
Superman started out he's got a Heavenly
set of parents by by the way and an
Earthly set of parents and he's an
orphan like Harry Potter very common
theme is that when Superman first
emerged he could only jump over
buildings you know and maybe he could
start a locomotive but by the time the
1980s rolled around like he could juggle
planets and you know swallow hydrogen
bombs and you know he could do anything
well people stop buying the Superman
comics because how interesting is that
it's like something horrible happens and
Superman deals with it and and something
else horrible happens and Superman deals
with it and it's like that's dull he
turned into such an archetype he was
basically the omniscient omnipresent um
om omnipotent God and that's no fun it's
like God wins and then God wins again
and then again God wins and you know so
then they had to weaken him in different
ways with Kryptonite you know so green
Kryptonite kind of made him sick and red
Kryptonite I think kind of mutated him
if I remember correctly and anyways they
had to introduce flaws into his
character so that there could be some
damn plot and that's something to think
about you know there's a deep
existential lesson in that in that
your being is limited and and flawed and
and fragile um you're like the genie
which is genius in the little tiny in
the little tiny uh lamp you know this
immense potential but constrained in
this tiny little living space as Robin
Williams said when he played the genie
in Aladdin but the fact that you have
limitations means that the plot of your
life is the overcoming of those
limitations and that if you didn't have
limitations well there wouldn't be a
plot and maybe there would be no life
and so that's part of the reason why
perhaps you have to accept the fact that
you're flawed and insufficient and and
live with it and consider it a
precondition for being it's at least a
reasonable it's a reasonable idea it's
one thing I did
1985 82 83
82 I I swore that I would stop lying I
said I'm going to try not to say
anything I know to be true you know that
doesn't mean I swore to tell the truth
cuz truth that's hard but you can
consciously stop lying when you know
you're lying you can stop doing that and
that has been revolutionary for me and
and one of the things I've really
realized in recent years and this is
very much worth knowing is that Mo many
times when people speak to each other
they have an agenda in mind you know you
want something from someone maybe you
want a job and you want to craft your
image to get the job job right so you
say what you need to say to get what you
think you need the problem with that is
what do you know about what you need
you're so accurate about that are you
and you think you know what you need
exactly and so you're going to falsify
your utterances to bring about the
desired end and you're going to use the
other person as a target of your
manipulation well that's like you write
an essay because that's what the
professor wants to hear it's like you
don't do that cuz you don't falsify your
words cuz hypothetically they're Divine
and the whole stability of the state
rest on them hypothetically and maybe
really too and so you don't do that and
so instead you strive to tell the truth
and maybe that's an A too and then it's
an adventure cuz I'll tell you one thing
if you tell the truth you have no idea
what's going to happen to you cuz you
have to let go of that it's like I'm
going to say what I think and then what
I'm going to assume faith I'm going to
assume that whatever happens if I am
telling the truth is the best thing that
could happen because the truth brings
about what is best and even if it looks
hard for me because it might be you know
cuz people take the easy way out often
when they lie even if it looks bad for
me that doesn't mean it's bad it just
means I don't see the whole I don't see
the whole picture and you know if you
believe that the truth will set you free
and that there is such a thing as the
truth and that the truth is Redemptive
then you're pretty much stuck with that
conclusion but one of the remarkable
things about that and this really is
worth knowing is that if you do that you
will have your
adventure right the that's the abrahamic
adventure you know the call from God
that justifies your life because of the
excitement of what you're doing and the
truth does that and then if it's the
truth man it's your adventure cuz what
bloody Adventure are you have if you
tell someone else's story it's not
yours and maybe if it's not yours it's
not good enough for you and then you
suffer and then you're bitter and then
you're cruel and then you're
resentful that's not good or you get
arrogant
so so you break up your life you don't
into practicalities your career your
education your intimate relationship
your marriage your friendship hopefully
your intimate relationship and your
marriage are the same
thing your use of time outside work your
civic duty you know and you develop an
image for yourself a vision for yourself
on all those fronts and assume that you
can have with the proper sacrifices what
you need and want and then I'll say
something interesting about that CU
that's the pursuit of goods in a
practical way right and what's valuable
in a practical way and an implementable
way and you pick those Pathways and you
dedicate yourself to their optimization
along any of those axes and then you
learn to optimize an aim and then you
see once you've learned to optimize an
aim across a set of goods you start to
aim at what is what unites those
goods what that's what makes Goods good
it's whatever is common AC cross a set
of goods that's the highest good or a
higher good and so by practicing any
good in any rigorous sense and making
the proper sacrifices in that direction
you simultaneously learn to approach the
good that is the sum or the essence of
all those proximal goods and I would say
that the the
essential insistence in Christianity is
that the good that unites all those
goods is the same good that's reflected
in the image of Christ which is an image
of
acceptance of the suffering of life and
the necessity of serving the lowest as
the highest
calling and that's something and it
might be
true like really actually 100% true more
true than anything else and I actually
think it is partly because the freest
societies that we have that the world's
ever known the most successful societies
are predicated on precisely that idea as
as an unshakable Foundation a
self-evident truth in the case of your
country and so it might be true and if
it is true and if that is real then why
in the world would you ever attempt to
do anything else and it's kind of Earth
shattering in some sense to take this
with real seriousness you know it's all
very frightening if you're not afraid by
of that of that Vision you know and what
it implies for you and your soul then
you didn't understand it but it's also
an
unbelievably what would you say
endlessly promising vision of what your
life could be and you know you might
think well I need a life so rich that I
can justify its suffering and that's
really asking for something because
there's no shortage of suffering in life
and it's no one thinks their own
suffering isn't real and maybe there's a
possibility that there's some aim that's
so high that that the
attempt that the attempt alone to move
in that direction is of sufficient value
to act as a Panacea for the suffering
and so you could say at the end of your
life oh my God that was so hard
hard was worth
it so that's the choice you make at the
crossroads if you have any sense the
more accurate a measure you take of
someone's political beliefs the more you
find that personality is what's
predicting them and I I think that's a
reasonable thing to think about because
you know you have to you have to figure
out ways of simplifying the world right
because you just can't do everything and
so people are specialized they have
specialized niches that they occupy you
could think about them as social niches
a niche is a place where your particular
skills would serve to maintain you and
so if you're
extroverted you're going to look for a
social Niche because you like to be
around people and if you're introverted
you're going to spend much more time on
your own and so if you're an introverted
person for example you're going to want
a job where you're not selling and where
you're not surrounded by groups of
people who are making social demands on
you all the time because it'll wear you
out whereas if you're extroverted that's
just exactly what you want and so the
extrovert sees the world as a place of
social opportunity and the introvert
sees the world as a place to retreat
from and spend time alone and it turns
out that both of those modes of being
are valid that the issue at least to
some degree is whether or not you're
fortunate enough to match your
temperament with the demands of the
environment and I suppose also whether
you're fortunate enough fortunate enough
so that you're born in an era where
they're is a niche for your particular
temperament because it isn't necessarily
the case that that will be the case
imagine that all of these temperamental
Dimensions vary because of evolutionary
pressure right so there's a distribution
of extraversion a normal distribution
most people are somewhere in the middle
and then as you go out towards the
extremes there are fewer and fewer
people and what that means is that on
average across large spans of time there
have been environments that match every
single position on that distribution
with most most of the environments
matching the center because otherwise we
wouldn't have evolved that way and so
sometimes being really extroverted is
going to work well for you in a minority
of environments a minority of niches and
sometimes it's just going to be a
catastrophe I suspect for example that
if you live in a tyrannical
Society where any sign of of of
of personally oriented activity is
likely to get you in trouble that being
extroverted and low in neuroticism
wouldn't be a very good idea because
you're going to be mouthy and happy and
saying a lot of things unable to keep
your thoughts to yourself and you're
going to be relatively Fearless now I
don't know that for sure because we'
haven't done the studies that precisely
match temperamental proclivity to
environmental demand but you get what I
mean don't make a plan that is what you
should do even though it will be what
you should do make a plan that outlines
a future so that you can sit back and
say look if I had that future then all
the horrible things that are going to
happen to me are going to be
worthwhile that's what you want you want
to think this game is worth playing
despite its tragedy that's what you've
got in life enough meaning to serve as
an antidote to tragedy all right now and
then you generate a strategy and then
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious industrious is
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that eat three times a day at r
meal times that's a good thing to
practice cuz that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time I would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly cuz you don't need as much sleep
but it's also partly cuz I've got more
and more disciplined like get up early
in the morning and get your things done
man learn to get up at 6:00 in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work work you'll have half your damn day
done by the time other people haul their
Sor asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive Advantage look will
frell um Warren frell not the comedian
Warren frell the author he outlined data
in why men earn more which is a book I
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 133% longer hours you make
40% more money it's nonlinear so you
think why is that well imagine you had
10 employees and one of them Works an
extra 10% it's not much well how often
is that person going to be promoted
assuming you have a clue as a boss it's
like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these T
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10% extra 13%
have nonproportional payoffs that's part
of the Paro distribution so get get get
your sleep cycle organized so you get up
in the morning learn how to do it no
excuses I'm too tired in the morning I
don't like mornings who cares that's not
relevant it's like discipline yourself
so you can manage it schedule your meals
cuz that's a good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
Google Calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly a
calendar keeps anxiety at Bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
it's also helps you plan what you want
to do so I could say well lay out your
damn
calendar and design the days you would
like to have that's what your calendar
is is for so you can put in all sorts of
things in there you want to do and that
would be good for you and that's a
really good really good way to start
being more industrious make a plan you
need a plan for 3 years you need a plan
for the next year you need a plan for
the next 6 months you need to plan for
the next 3 months you need a plan for
the week you need a plan for the day you
need to plan for the hour all of that
all of that I make lists constantly of
what I have to do and they're like daily
weekly monthly yearly right now I can't
look out more than about 6 months you
know cuz my life is too complicated and
chaotic but but you need a vision of who
you could be what character you could
have 3 to 5 years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable I think to make Vision
that's longer term than
that subject
to there's to too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to 5 years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and what because what are
you going to do you going to stumble
around and get get what you need you're
going to stumble around and be useful to
other people and it's useful to be
useful to other people you know they
want to work with you then they want to
do things with you they want to have you
around they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a b that's hell that's a
bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it and or or aim for the
opposite cuz that's how you get out of
it you should treat yourself like you're
someone responsible for helping
and the first question is well why don't
you and the answer is well there's a lot
wrong with you you know and it's hard
to exercise enough love and care in a
deep and non-naive way to care properly
for something like that it's an
encouragement to assume to act out the
prop position that even if life is as
difficult as it seems to be and if
you're as vulnerable and weak in a
fundamental sense as you definitely are
and characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of
voluntary suffering on yourself and
others and that destructive tendency
that there's still something within you
that's so remarkable and
so aligned with with order and being in
the proper manner that you can climb
above that let's say like able and that
you can make the proper sacrifices and
that you can set yourself right and you
can set your family right and you can
set the world right and that the mere
possibility that that might occur that
that might be within the realm of
potential means that you have a moral
obligation to exercise the
responsibility to take care of yourself
as if you're something that matters and
that if you did that properly it might
turn out that what you did would matter
that it would matter to you that it
would be meaningful in the way that
things that matter are meaningful and
that it would matter to everyone around
you if you've explicitly formulated a
set of goals and you're pursuing them
then you've adopted the responsibility
to act in a certain manner to make those
goals realize themselves that's that's
responsibility that you've adopted
rather than responsibility that's being
imposed on you assuming that you've
thought through the goals and you find
your spirit in harmony with those goals
um you can consult your resentment I
think that's a very useful step if you
find yourself angry and bitter about the
things that you are responsible for
doing then that's an indication that you
might be operating under some unhealthy
compulsion that you're rebelling and
that's the reason for the resentment
against the insistence that you act in a
certain
way although it's also possible that
you're just immature and that you're
rebelling against the discipline that's
necessary to attain the goals that you
genuinely do want to attain and that are
valid and that you
are what actively engaged in
constructing so you have to get that
straight and some of that's a
consequence of thought and again some of
that's a consequence of of discussion
with other
people with whom
you're intimate enough to have a
conversation like that and perhaps they
have conversations about similar things
with you if you're fortunate when you
were possessed by those ideas you might
have been at least partially authentic
because one of the things you might ask
yourself is well were they Stepping
Stones to a better you you know people
get possessed all the time because they
admire certain ideas and sometimes that
admiration impels them into a kind of
apprenticeship and so they were stupider
before they got possessed by that idea
and as
they trans transformed themselves across
the apprenticeship cycle say being
Apprentice to this fadlik idea they
learned something from it so you know
you might you might have learned and
grown as a consequence of what possessed
you now you know it's possible that a
lot of that spoke to the development of
parts of you that you don't want to
develop you know that they spoke to your
malevolence and spoke to your desire to
manipulate and all of that and you have
to sort that out but look I also don't
think it's all that easy to figure out
when you're authentic that that's subtle
you know you you your felt sense of
confidence in your words when you're not
trying to win is something like your
ability to judge your authenticity you
know are you saying this to achieve a
local end or are you saying this because
you have thought deeply and this is the
best expression you can manage of a
deeply held conviction that's a lifetime
it's a lifetime of work or it's a
lifetime work to sort those things out
the best I could come up with was in my
first book well the first of the more
popular books
in 12 rules for life
um don't lie now not lying is not the
same as being authentic exactly
because as your question highlights it's
not that easy to tell when you're
telling the truth right because well
what the hell do you know it's certainly
not the truth what you know it might be
your best approximation but it's
certainly not the truth and you're by no
means uniring in your ability to discern
when it is that you're even speaking
your truth because that's so complicated
you just have to practice doing that
continually to get anywhere near good at
it like it's years and years of effort
to of stringent moral effort to begin to
manage that but I do believe that people
can tell by and large when they're
outright lying and they can stop doing
that they can stop saying things they
know to be false and so that's the most
obvious impediment to authenticity is
outright lies of commission stop
engaging in those stop saying things you
know to be false now that begs the
questions how do you know them to be
false well that's complicated sometimes
that's a feeling of repugnance at your
own words sometimes it's a feeling of
touchy embarrassment so that if people
call you in what you say you get
disproportionately angry um sometimes
it's knowing a set of facts that that
you haven't let effect the way you think
or present yourself you know you're
purposefully keeping yourself in the fog
as per rule three of Beyond order um
those are all things you have to sort
out for yourself but I think it starts
with an Act of Faith and which is at
least in part why religious systems
insist upon faith and Faith isn't belief
in something that no unsane would
believe you know that's that's a
misapprehension of faith faith is
something like a decision
that truth serves the good and the good
is worth serving and so therefore truth
is worth serving it's just that's an
axiomatic proposition and you can debate
its empirical justification and of
course we wouldn't be tempted into
temptation if we couldn't debate its
empirical justification because the
objection is yeah and what exactly does
truth buy you that falsehood wouldn't
buy you better and if you don't think
that you're tempted by that
counterposition well then you don't know
anything about Temptation because that
is the temptation of the
counterposition so and it's powerful
Temptation that's why it's a statement
of faith that dis that that um conquers
it it's a
decision
so you probably were possessed by an
idea but maybe there was something in
you that was striving to be authentic
and maybe you can speed that process of
transformation Along by vowing by taking
a vow and that's adopting a religious
commitment which is I'm going to serve
truth and the good despite the proximal
cost and that's a statement of faith
because you're staking your life on that
right because every decision you make
from here on in will be a will be
affected by that by that decision so
it's a fundamental decision ision and
hopefully that will guide you in your
endeavors so that your possession by
cultural fads which might be a necessary
part of your apprenticeship will be
temporary and serve this zigzagging path
to something that's better for you in
the future pick something aim at it as
you move toward it you'll get wiser then
maybe your aim will change that's okay
but at least it'll change in an informed
way it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension see what happens well that's
exciting and I think that's something
that's open for everyone you can do that
I shouldn't say that because I don't
believe that I think you can find
yourself in situation that's so dire
that you don't there's no escape from it
but that doesn't matter because this
still this is the hero myth might not
be the best we have might not always
work
but it's still the best we
have and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it
away it's still the best we have I mean
everyone dies and so we fail in some
sense the fact that a symphony ends
doesn't mean that it wasn't worth
listening to you look where you think
it's important to
look so I'll say that again you look
where you think it's important to look
and that means that well a hierarchy of
importance is no different than a
hierarchy of value they are the same
thing a hierarchy of priority is the
same as a hierarchy of value and a
hierarchy of priority and a hierarchy of
value and an ethic are all the same
thing right because you're going to look
at what you believe to be of cardinal
importance otherwise you look well if
you're talking to someone and you look
at their
feet that's not going to be going very
well right first of all they're not
going to be very impressed with you CU
they actually want you to look at their
eyes and that's because we communicate
value with their eyes and we do that
directly our eyes have even evolved to
do that our eyes have whites around the
iris so that you can see where people
Point them because it's that important
to know what people think is important
we see the world through a structure of
value and I think that a huge part of
that structure of value is actually
derived from the entire set of texts
entire set of texts and they inter
relationship that have the biblical
Corpus at their base and so it seems to
me that you I think you can make a
pretty damn strong
case maybe on scientific grounds that
you can't see the world except through
the lens of the
Bible like literally you actually can't
see it now if it's not the Bible it
might be some other Corpus of texts but
it might be it isn't and if it was well
is it going to be a corpus of texts that
we share because if it isn't then we
can't share our perceptions and our
values and if we can't share those then
we fight those are the options right we
either stabilize our hierarchies of
value in some way that we agree upon
mutually or we fight that's or we're
unbelievably chaotic and confused and
that'll just produce fighting in any
case and so we have this structure of
texts built from the bottom up it's
predicated on the biblical
narratives and the texts exist in
relationship to those underlying
narratives and derive a fair of their
meaning from the meaning of the
underlying narratives and and vice versa
you know
um and so then the biblical is it
possible that biblical truth is the sort
of truth that is the precondition for
truth right because you think well it's
religious people make the claim people
of the Bible make the claim the Bible is
true well there's all sorts of different
kinds of truth that's that's an
interesting claim but it's not very
elaborated it's it's
insufficient um and you know often what
happens to Christians when they debate
skilled atheists like Richard Dawkins as
they treat the Bible like it's a
scientific theory and Dawkins just mops
the floor with them because it's
actually not a scientific theory
compared to scientific theories and so
as soon as you go there well it's like a
scientific theory it's like no it's not
it's not and so does that mean it's not
true well it means that if the only
thing you think is true is a scientific
theory
but I don't think that you can practice
science except within an ethical
framework that's not in itself science
and so it's possible that there is a
deeper truth than the scientific truth
which is the ethic that has to be there
a priority before you can even begin to
do science we should make much more of
an effort to ensure that kids are
unbelievably proficient readers and a
lot of that is going to involve early
automatization of letter and phon name
and syllable and word recognition so
because what happens is when you teach a
child to read first of all you teach
them the alphabet and the sounds and we
have an alphabetic language thank God
because it makes things much simpler and
so you teach them the letters and then
the two-letter combinations and then the
three-letter
combinations then they can sound out
syllables and then they get words but it
isn't until you can read phrases
automatically at a glance that you can
read for content and pleasure and so a
lot of kids get stuck especially if they
don't come from particularly literate
homes where where all of this is sort of
taught you know maybe starting at you
know 12 months when they're first
dragging a book around and and becoming
familiar with the book as an object
right before they even learn to read you
got to get kids through that
automatization phase and that requires
intense Mass practice and that's not
that intrinsically interesting right but
if you can get them to the point where
they could read for Content well then it
starts to become interesting just as
interesting let's say as going to a
movie or perhaps playing a video game
and so that has to be made an absolute
priority and and the F if the faculties
of Education were doing their job they
would have produced technology to solve
that problem for virtually every child
because it is only a matter of practice
smarter kids will learn faster but with
enough practice pretty much everybody is
going to get there so and then there's
the marketing issue it's like well why
why should you read well do you want to
be
stupid you want to be stupid what
happens when you're stupid you walk into
walls cuz you don't see them and if
someone comes along who's more educated
than you more literate and cannier
they'll just you'll lose man you'll lose
and you'll lose too because you can't
think properly so you won't aim at the
right things and you won't be informed
by the great individuals of the past and
you need that we're historical creatures
this isn't
optional so part part of it has to be
marketing for lack of a better word it's
not really that it's an explanation why
be literate because it makes you it
helps you become who you could be helps
you move out into the world and have
your great adventure and to bring people
along God only knows what you can do if
you've got your words lined up properly
and young men would listen to that if
someone who knew what they were talking
about was telling them
that as you found out if you want an
answer to the first question which is
how do I find the person who's right for
me you actually start by asking the
second question which is what can I
bring to the table for someone else and
if you're really good at bringing
something to the table for someone else
hey man people might be lining up to be
your partner and if they're not then you
might think well maybe I'm just not
bringing the right thing to the table
and that's worth thinking especially if
you're desperate you're lost and you're
alone it's like hm maybe I got this
wrong and I you know I usually sort of
top that with the suggestion that even
if you did find the person who was
perfect for you and they're that perfect
what makes you think they wouldn't take
one look at you and run screaming away
and they likely would if they were that
perfect because you know really are you
that much of a
catch and if you think you are you know
that might be part of the problem
um so so look so that's one right
intimate relationship so I would say to
you at the crossroads develop a vision
for your relation ship how do you bear
the suffering that is at the Crux of
life without becoming tempted and
embittered that's really really
difficult now you know someone might
point out go ahead and be bitter see
where that gets you and if you have any
sense and generally people have at least
some they know that being sick and
bitter is worse than just being sick and
that being right it's worse but it's
very hard temptation to avoid sometimes
you want to be bitter just out of spite
in some sense because things are so
terrible all you've got left is your
willingness to shake your fist you know
and say well you know really is this
like this many poisonous snakes really
that's like maybe I could have learned
with just one or two not a hundred and
so but we're stuck we're all stuck with
that and I think we're stuck with it at
every level of our life in some sense is
how do we maintain a high order moral
orientation in spite of suffering and
malevolence yeah I first started to
understand that what we perceive in some
real sense isn't exactly material
reality and partly that's because that's
actually
impossible and I mean that technically
and that's something we could go into in
great depth because that realization
paralyzed a number of fields it really
started to come to the Forefront many
fields in about in the early 1960s
especially in AI when the AI type
started to try to make machines that
could see the world in some sense like
we do and then act in the world and what
they instantly realized was that
oh there isn't just something there that
we see this is way harder than we ever
possibly imagined in fact it's so hard
that it looks like it might be
impossible in some sense so how the hell
do we do it and like we still don't have
robots that can move around the world
like we do you know endless not sure I'm
not I'm not maybe it's improved the last
time I looked at this great detail we
didn't have robots that could fold
laundry very efficiently either so yeah
well a lot of these so-called simple
things like seeing well it's half your
brain it takes you half your brain to
see and most animals like we see way
better than almost all animals Eagles
Raptors really cuz I we have bald eagles
in my backyard yeah they can see they
they their eyes are the same size as
yours and they have two fovial spots
Eagles uh Falcons they're the animals
that can see better than us but other
than
that it's us and it's half our brain
just to see well so why well you're a
physicist you understand that reality is
composed of levels of being right from
the subatomic up to the cosmic it's like
well first of all how do you specify the
proper level of
analysis well one of the things that's
quite interesting psychologically is
that we have short words are generally
used to describe things that manifest
themselves to us at our level of
analysis cat we see a cat we don't see a
species we don't see cat sub parts we
see this cat well why well that's that's
the level that's most biologically
relevant to us given our embodiment
that's an evolutionary answer and so we
see what we see first of all what we see
a lot of is memory but we see something
that's overlaid on the world we actually
see the overlay and hopefully it
reflects what's underneath and generally
it does and it's a hell of a shock to us
when when we make a perceptual
error but I see I and then I started to
learn especially from Reading Jeffrey
gray that we we also see the world
within a motivated frame and he was
influenced by Norbert weiner who was one
of the world's first cybernetic
scientists essentially a great influence
on AI yeah and and gray never talked
about narrative but the frame that he
described that we see and in animals as
well basically has a point a and a point
B so we're always moving towards a goal
if we're mobile animals and I thought Oh
Well the description of the movement
from point A to point B that's the
simplest unit of meaning that's a story
and then I learned that a better story
is a story about how stories transform
and so those are actually perceptual
frames of reference that transform and
then I understood
that if you don't have respect for the
transformation process process above all
else then you can't transform your
perceptual frames when necessary and
then you can't adapt to error and that
destroys you and so that's that's all
part of that the truth is Redemptive
right and this is this is another of the
Great accomplishments of Freud because
Freud shed new light on the logos in
some ways right because Freud understood
that true speech
heals right I mean that's his his entire
therapeutic approach is bring people in
and
don't disturb them when they're trying
to tell you something let them say
anything absolutely and that's what he
told his clients too is like say
whatever comes to your mind right let no
matter how off color off-putting
embarrassing shameful aggressive
sexual find out who you are that's the
first draft lay yourself out on the
table and while he had them laid
themselves out on the couch he hid from
his clients so they couldn't he was
afraid that if they saw his face they
would censor themselves by watching his
emotional reactions so he sat off to the
side of his clients so they could just
say what they had to say with no
interference
and you know this because you're an
educator
but people
cannot organize themselves and come to
who they are without laying themselves
out and they can't lay themselves out
without thinking or talking most people
think by talking in fact you learn to
think by talking you can't talk if no
one listens most people most people have
no one to listen to them I want to tell
you a little bit about how to
conceptualize Free Will I think first
because it's obvious that we don't have
infinite free will our our choice our
choices are constrained in all sorts of
ways and I think part of the reason that
there's a a continual discussion about
Free Will in the philosophic
in the philosophical literature is
because just conceptualizing the issue
properly is extraordinarily difficult so
I like to think about it at least in
part the way that you think about a game
you know if you're playing a game
obviously the game has rules so if it's
a chess game or a basketball game then
there are things that you can do and and
things that you can't do and but and so
it's it's a it's a it's a closed World
in some sense
but the fact that there are things you
can't do when you play a game also seem
to open up a universe of possibilities
for things that you can do so chess
obviously constrains you to a board and
to a certain number of men and to a
certain pattern of rules but the strange
thing is is that when you put in those
rules because rules sound like limits
they sound always like things you can't
do but when you set up a constrained
world like that and you lay out a system
of rules what you do is open up an
Infinity of of a near Infinity of
possibilities same with music You Know
music has rules obviously and and if you
follow the rules then you can make an
infinite variety of music and so and so
there's a there's a very interesting
Dynamic that's hard to understand
between constraint and possibility and
there's a deep idea that's associated
with that that I read in some Jewish
commentary on on the biblical stories
that I I read a long time ago um talking
about the Rel a ship between God and man
and the idea was that
God imagine a being with the classical
attributes of God omniscience
omnipotence and omnipresence allseeing
all knowing and all powerful what is a
being like that lack and obviously the
answer is nothing right because by
definition those three
traits provide for absence of limitation
but then that's exactly what's lacking
is limitation and there's some strange
connection between limitation and and I
was saying say
limitation that that's rule governed as
I mentioned before and the opening up of
possibility so it isn't necessarily the
case that now deter determinism and
limitation aren't exactly the same thing
but they're analogous and they need to
be discussed together okay so now so
that's the first thing is that our
whatever our free choice is it isn't
limited it's or it's limited it's it's
deeply limited now here's another thing
if I take my arm and go like this you
see I'll do that again now you see
there's a movement like that and then my
hands stop just before my my other hand
now it takes a certain amount of time
for the neural messages to go from my
brain to my arm and back and the time it
takes my hand to go like this and stop
is actually shorter than the time it
takes a message to get to my brain and
back so what that means is that when I
when I plan this movement which is
called a ballistic movement it's called
a ballistic movement because it's like a
bullet once you let it go it's gone
there's no calling it back I've actually
organized the neurological and muscular
sequences that enable that action before
it's implemented I set all that up and
then it's released and the whole thing
Cascades and so once the action has been
released let's say then I don't really
have any free will because I can't stop
it now so so you think about that it
looks like there's a temporal grad with
regards to Free Will is that as you look
out into the future may perhaps the
farther out you look into the future um
the farther down the road let's say the
more free your choices are but the
closer they get to implementation the
more they become deterministic governed
by standard causal processes and there's
some transition point where they change
from being what we would describe as
choice that we haven't got to free
choice yet but at least to choice
there's some transition point point
between that and Ballistic movement it's
not all that happens though when they
eat the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil because it's
not called the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of nakedness it's called the
fruit of the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil and I thought about that
for a tremendous amount of time it's
like what in the world because I assume
these old stories make sense you know
it's a game I play it's like they're old
they've been around a long time I'm not
sure why they're there but there they
are they're at the basis of our culture
like many many of the stories that we
depend on depend on them our whole
culture grew out of their Roots let's
say and so I assume that our ancestors
who managed to survive conditions that
would have done a lot of us in very
rapidly I can tell you were a lot
smarter than we think and that the
mysterious processes that that produced
these stories and compelled us to
remember them are a lot more
psychologically significant than we
generally tend to presume so I give them
the benefit of the doubt and try to
understand why it is that they might
make sense instead of assuming that they
don't and that that's not easy as they
complicated stories and so I thought
about this nakedness knowledge of Good
and Evil idea for a very very long time
like about 20 years puzzling it out was
what the hell is the relationship
between discovering that you're naked
and discovering good and evil and then
one day mostly because of studying
totalitarian ISM totalitarianism and the
atrocity the proclivity for people to
commit atrocity in the service of their
group belief or maybe just because
that's what they were like um clued me
in and I thought I see this is one of
the things that really makes people
different than animals it's like you
know it's one thing to realize that
you're naked to realize that you're
naked means that you know that you're
limited in time and space that you're
mortal and that you're you're subject to
degeneration and to social humiliation
and to your own harsh judgment all of
that nakedness to Know That You're
vulnerable against the world and
definitely a source of Shame um because
of that um and and a felt lack of
self-sufficiency and and no wonder and
no wonder um it's understandable but the
other thing is is that this is and this
is the rub it's like if you're out in
the velt and you're not being very
careful and a hungry lion jumps on you
and eats you you don't really think of
the lion as evil I mean you might write
at that moment but you know
philosophically it's not evil it's just
hungry and as soon as it's not hungry
then it goes and has asleep and it's not
up to some malevolent trick it's it's
done for the day but human being that's
a whole different sort of creature and
because human being is capable of doing
terrible things to someone else and
consciously so you think well what's the
connection between that and nakedness
itself and it seems to be this is like
here's the thing is that once I realize
that I can be hurt you know I have a
self-conscious model of my own
vulnerability then I can generalize that
to other people I can think oh this is
interesting here's how I can be hurt by
myself here's how I can be hurt by
Society here's how I can be hurt by
nature and by the unknown and that
implies is that well you can be hurt
with exactly the same
mechanisms and that immediately becomes
part of
my what would you say my repertoire of
ability and then all of a sudden you the
world is no longer a
walled a Walled Garden and a
well-watered place but it's a moral
story because with that ability to
inflict suffering comes the knowledge of
good and evil as far as I'm concerned
those are identical propositions because
now we have the choice a deep choice
about how we're going to treat ourselves
and each other we can inflict tremendous
pain and suffering on each other in a
very voluntary and and conscious manner
in in in a way that no other animal can
manage and that's the dawning of the
moral sense that capacity we now have to
choose to mitigate or exaggerate
suffering and and that's not all but
it's a huge part of it of course you're
going to be disenchanted because you
were young and naive and so being
disenchanted is part of maturing but the
next part of maturing is to move forward
optimistically as an axiom of your faith
in mankind and yourself as a recognition
of your moral obligation to do so right
so now your eyes are open you see well
you know there's a snake in the
garden and Cain is your
brother well yeah it's always been that
way a welcome to reality so what do you
do you allow that to make you corrupt
and
nihilistic not if you think that it's
the corruption and the nihilism that's
the problem so you're obligated to be
optimistic in some
sense despite the evidence and that's
faith
so you know pick up your cross and
stumble
uphill
consciously and you bring back optimism
in human relations by structuring your
own to the best of your possible
ability and that'll expand outward as
you become more competent move through
your life be
productive generous kind Discerning wise
educated you be a good father to
everyone not the Tyrant that resentment
breeds in your own
heart and that's an act of moral
courage and that's real
maturity so and and if you want an
adventure well there's one for you is
habit the the maintenance the
development maintenance of good
practices
habits if you find yourself dissolute uh
neurotic if your tant if your thought
tends in the nihilistic direction and
you tend to fall
apart organizing
your life across multiple Dimensions is
a good antidote it's not exactly
thinking do you have an intimate
relationship if not well probably you
could use use
one do you have contact with close
family members siblings or children or
parents or or or people who are even
more distantly related if not you
probably need that do you see your
friends a couple of times a week and do
something social with them uh do you
have a way of productively using your
time outside of employment are you
employed do you have a good job or at
least a job that
is practically sufficient and that
enables you to work with people who you
like working with even if the job itself
is you know mundane or repetitive or
difficult sometimes the relationships
that you
establish with it in in a employment
situation like that can make the job
worthwhile um have you regulated your
response to Temptations pornography
alcohol abuse drug abuse use is that
under
control um I would say differentiate the
problem there's
multiple dimensions of
attainment
ambition pleasure responsibility all of
that that make up a life and to the
degree that it's possible you want to
optimize your functioning on as many of
those Dimensions as possible you might
also organize
schedule to the degree that you have
that capacity for discipline do you get
enough sleep do you go to bed at a
regular time do you get up at a regular
time do you eat regularly and
appropriately and enough and not too
much uh are your days and your weeks and
your months characterized by some
tolerable repeatable
structure that helps you meet your
responsibilities but also Shields you
from uncertainty and chaos and provides
you with multiple sources of
reward those are all the questions that
I
would decompose the problem into the
best way to avoid falling back into
nihilistic behaviors and thinking if
you're looking for
certainty the reality of suffering is
certain I mean what do you accept as
evidence above all else that's a good
question that's a hard question but I
would say pain is up there it's very
difficult not to believe in the reality
of your own pain um it's somewhat easier
not to believe in the reality of other
people's pain that's not so easy either
you know um but it's your pain seems to
be undeniably
real and so it does beg a question which
is you know if pain is undeniably real
is that which overcomes pain even more
real and I think that's in some sense
that's the idea that lurks behind the
idea of the Resurrection people have
like three well they have four
fundamental fears one is fear of their
own inadequacy and malevolence that's
that's a big fear man that can really
that can really do you in if you
confront it
accidentally and fully happens to
soldiers sometimes in battle when they
find themselves doing things they can't
believe they do and then we're afraid of
society that would be the oppressive
patriarchy because Society judges us
harshly and and mercilessly in many ways
and we don't like to plummet in
the what would you call it we don't like
to see our reputation Savaged in front
of the groups that we identify with it's
extraordinarily hard on us emotionally
for that to happen which I wrote about
for example in rule one which is a uh a
chapter at least in part that details
out the fact that the neurochemical
systems that track your comparative
status in competence hierarchies also
regulate the balance between your
positive and negative emotion such that
if you suffer a social defeat your
proclivity to experience negative
emotion radically increases and your
proclivity to experience positive
emotion radically decreases and people
seriously do not like that and it's no
wonder because who wants to be
completely overwhelmed with sadness and
bitterness and anxiety and resentment
and disappointment and frustration and
grief and then also devoid of happiness
you know it's the very definition of
hell and if a status defeat will
increase that probability then we will
fight very hard to maintain our status
positions which we certainly do that's
another fear and then of course we have
the fear of Nature and we should because
of course nature despite being the
environment and this thing that we
should be striving to protect and
maintain is also trying with all of its
might constantly to make us ill and old
and kill us and is generally very
successful all three and so there's
every reason to be afraid of Nature and
um you know one night alone in the bush
will pretty
much convince you of that and then
people are also afraid of the unknown
and so those are the big categories of
Terror that human beings face and to be
naked on stage is to face at least two
or three of those simultaneously don't
falsify your words to please anyone
including the professors you
know you think about it so you think
well I need to get the grade so I have
to tell him or her what they want to
hear first of
all you're probably not wise enough to
be that
cynical you know there are plenty of
professors who are ideologically
possessed but most of them aren't entire
so very rarely that's the case for
everyone and you have to be pretty
Twisted as an
academic to not recognize something of
quality even if you disagree with it and
so I have to write what they want to
hear might mean I can't write so if
I take the easy root I raise the
probability I won't fail slightly and
that doesn't justify your cynicism it
just means it's directed outward instead
of being directed inward which would be
the proper thing to do and then the next
thing you might think is what exactly
are you learning to do at University
maybe your goal at University when it is
to some degree ideologically addled is
to learn how to tell the truth in the
face in the face of opposition and maybe
if you practice doing that for four
years youd really get an education when
you organize your perceptions around a
goal that provides a container for your
negative emotion so if I want to walk
across the stage because I think that
getting to the other side is preferable
to being here so that's a hierarchy of
value that place is better than this
place then when I observe myself
undertaking the actions that will get me
to that place that's comforting and
provides security because it shows that
the structure that I'm using to organize
my perceptions and to reduce the world
to a manageable
to
manageability is sufficiently accurate
so that I can implement it and so we
seem to inhabit those structures all the
time whenever we're looking at the world
whenever we're interacting we specify a
goal and so that's an ethical Enterprise
and we organize our emotions within the
specification of that goal and then we
produce hierarchies of goals so you know
you go to you you sit down in front of
your computer so you can write a paper
and you write a paper so that you can
finish an essay and you finish an essay
so that you can get a grade in the class
and get a grade in the class so that you
can graduate with a degree and you do
that so that you can get a job and you
do that so that you can be what a good
husband a good wife a good citizen and
you do that so you can be a good person
there's a hierarchy of ethic that
permeates the entire Enterprise right
from the microcosm up to the macrocosm
and I think that's something like the
whole landscape of religious value with
the outermost container so be a good
person let's say that's the ultimate aim
of the religious Enterprise that's
something like the imitation of Christ
in the most fundamental sense and all
the things that you do within that or
reflection of that or you're confused
and chaotic and if everyone's doing that
at the same time then you have a society
that's integrated and aiming up and
capable of telling the truth is
something like that does that seem
reasonable and so so what's the
proposition here well I think when we
describe these Frameworks of
perception the name we give to the
description of a framework of perception
is a story and I think the reason that
we like stories so much is because we
need to establish Frameworks of
perception in order to operate in the
world and to allow ourselves
to be integrated peacefully with other
people and so we're extraordinarily
interested in anything that has a
narrative basis and the reason we're
interested in that is because we're
trying to build within ourselves and
collectively the structure that enables
us to perceive the world without undue
confusion and chaos and in a manner that
provides some value to us and some
sustainability that's the goal
overall
and that seems to me to be the goal of
the entire religious Enterprise and
so is it possible that that well I guess
that's is that's the claim I thought I'd
elaborate out a little bit today is
that the Bible is true in a very strange
way it's true in
that it provides the basis
for truth
itself and so it's like a meta truth
right without it there without it there
couldn't even be the possibility of
Truth
and so maybe that's the most true thing
the most true thing isn't some truth per
se it's that which provides the
precondition for all judgments of Truth
and it seems to me
that I can't see any holes in that
argument and I can't see any holes in it
from a scientific perspective either
because I think we do know well enough
now as scientists that the problem of
deriving ethical direction from the
collection of facts is an intractable
problem there's too many facts there's
an infinite number of facts they do not
provide an uniring guide for Action they
can't there's twoo many of them they
have to be
prioritized and as soon as they are
prioritized well then you're in the
ethical domain and then that begs the
question what's the valid ethical domain
and the postmodern answer is well there
isn't one it's all the expression of
domination and power and I I think
that's nonsense I I don't think that's a
tenable solution I think that we
stumbled on to the proper answer in some
sense in our religious Enterprise which
is that we aim at what's highest or or
we don't we aim at what's highest
jointly or we're divided we aim at
what's highest and that's gives meaning
to all the things we do that are
subordinate parts of that we aim at
what's highest and that's what collects
us and gives us structure all of that
you know singly and jointly and that's
all what we've been trying to
communicate all these centuries as we've
been trying to communicate the whole
religious Corpus generation after
generation and to sort this out and to
straighten it out and to try to
understand it and uh I think that's
where we're at now when you see people
who are Noble in spite of their
suffering it is ennobling it is
uplifting like really it is and um and
it it's been striking to me too people
want to be encouraged in that direction
I mean part of the reason that my
lectures I would say they have been
successful to the degree that they have
been is because people find them
encouraging and that actually seems to
work like it seems to be positive
because it isn't NE good news well it
seems to be I mean it isn't necessarily
the case that that would be the case you
know because it could have been that I
would have said encouraging things to
people there's more to you that meets
the eye and you're capable of more than
you're demanding of yourself and you
know if you took on your responsibility
and faced the things that you're trying
to avoid that you're would be richer and
better and for you and for everyone
around you and the result of that could
have been that thousands of people would
come to me and say you know I gave that
a pretty good shot and it your advice is
really awful and everything is well
seriously like I took on that
responsibility it just bloody crushed me
and I'm way worse off than I was before
and everything's gone to hell around me
and like thanks a lot buddy and that and
that it's not like that's a
completely incomprehensible Poss
possibility but that doesn't seem to be
what happens is what generally happens
is that young people in particular but
not only come to me and say look I've
been trying to take on more
responsibility and to face the things
I've been avoiding and everything is way
better it's like okay well hm isn't that
something on something well then you ask
yourself what's the limit of that
because that's the religious question
fundamentally is well if you took on all
the responsibility you could take on and
you faced everything that you needed to
face what would you be like who would
you be and how would the world transform
around you and well if if the partial
answer is well if I do that a little bit
things get a fair bit better then the
next question might be well what if you
did that completely and I don't think
that's possible in some sense right it's
like you know Perfection is a horizon
that always recedes but it isn't obvious
to me what the upper limit of that is
and certainly we do see people I mean
Saints that's you say it's a mother it's
a Francis of who kind of push the limit
and they miraculous things happen around
them maybe in the literal sense and if
not in the literal sense close enough
you know for all intents and purposes
and so that's heartening I mean
I tear myself apart about this in many
ways because I think perhaps it's
possible to take on too much responsibil
and to crush yourself as a consequence
maybe that's a sin of Pride who knows
it's certainly possible but my
experience so far has been
that when you see people bear their
suffering
nobly there's nothing in that but
good that's something and then when you
see people take on more responsibility
and decide that they're going to aim up
and and confront their suffering
honestly and forthrightly that they're
like lives get better and the lives of
people around them get better too and so
it's that's very strange as well because
it also means that the pathway to less
suffering is through
suffering right and that's kind of that
would be hopeful if the world was
constituted that way it's like well
they're suffering how do you make it
worse run
away how do you make it better confront
it yeah but it's suffering it's like
yeah but it's there there it is it's
right there it's a pre condition for
existence or something like that and
it's like you have something important
to do as well and you confront it and
that's the pathway to transcending it
you mentioned earlier that at times
you're you're boiling inside uh I
certainly have experienced that
personally now anger how would you
distinguish and and I sort of
intuitively know these are different but
I would struggle to maybe on the spot
separate the two anger and resentment
because uh one of your
quotes that I have here in front of me
with my notes is consult your resentment
it is revelatory and I'd love to unpack
I'd love to unpack that uh but if you
could walk us through yeah well in my
new book I have a chapter which is Rule
11 do not allow yourself to become
resentful deceitful or arrogant it's
kind of the evil Triad as far as I've
been able to determine resentment in
particular it's bad it's a it's a bad
emotion it's useful you can learn a lot
by noticing that it occurs resentment
tells you one of two
things um one is that um you're that
someone's treading on your territory and
something needs to be done about it or
that you need to grow the hell up and
stop complaining and it's hard it isn't
necessarily obvious when you feel
resentful which of those it
is but you need to figure it out you
know because you
can you can Harbor resentment for for
unlived life for for very very long
period of time and all it does is
corrupt you it hurts you it hurts you
physically because it's a stressful
emotion anger is a stressful emotion
um because your body hyper prepares for
Action if you're angry because you might
get into conflict so and that's a
high that's a danger situation and so
you burn off a lot of
psychophysiological
resources in Anger um if you're
resentful there's probably something you
need to say there's certainly something
you need to figure
out and so you can you can use it as a
guide to further development it's very
much useful to to aim at a resentment
free existence and that means I suppose
that you're taking up enough space you
know you're not there's always a
struggle between your domain and the
domain of other people Everyone competes
for everyone else's attention everyone
competes for everyone else's time you
compete for your own time and if you're
resentful it's highly probable that well
as I said either you're not standing up
for yourself sufficiently or someone is
legitimately on your case in which case
you well you need to do something about
that or you know live with the
consequences which is very unpleasant
it's not optimal sometimes I suppose
it's
unavoidable but you know generally
there's something that can be done about
it maybe you need a new job I don't know
what percentage of human effort is spent
in counterproductive activity you know I
I'm I'm not an absolute cynic about that
but I mean when I talk to undergraduates
I ask them you know how much time do you
waste every day by your own Rec in and
it's somewhere between 5 and 8 hours you
know it's a lot of it's a lot of time
well I usually walk through I walk the
St students through an economic analysis
of that I said well you know why don't
you value your time at $50 an hour and
calculate for yourself just exactly what
you're doing to your future by your
inability to discipline yourself it's
worth thinking through in any case
people do waste a lot of time and they
they also act counterproductively a lot
of the time how do we
as human beings think about reputation
and does reputation even matter anymore
if anyone can try to tear your
reputation down should we be focused on
having a good reputation yes
or and how do we you should you should
you should be more focused on deserving
a good reputation what does that mean
don't don't do things you know to be
wrong and even if you don't lie yeah
don't lie don't be
careless you I mean es especially if
you're see I'm fortunate I I
suppose I put all my lectures
online so virally everything I've ever
said to a student is I mean obviously
not but a nonbiased sample of everything
that I've ever said to students is
available well it hasn't come back to
bite me right and that's hundreds of
hours why well because I've been
fortunate enough not to have said
anything um
fatal and you
know maybe that's because I'm careful
with my words I would say I mean we
don't understand Consciousness we don't
really understand its place in the
cosmos let's say but I'm not qualified
to answer such questions I would say
though that no no one stops listening to
a symphony because they know it's going
to end and so I think in some sense our
proper task is to find the meaning
within the finite when I had clinical
clients who were consumed with such
questions because you know you can pick
a time frame of evaluation that makes
all your efforts futile right well the
Sun is going to envelop the earth I I
think it's 4 billion years so like get
ready it's like well what's the point of
stopping this baby from crying when the
sun is going to envelop the Earth and
for well yeah you all laugh right but
but that laughter you see that's a sign
of wisdom you know that's
preposterous well
why I mean that's the existential
question right it's like well if all if
we're all doomed to ashes and Decay why
do anything well I used the baby crying
for a reason I mean who in the world is
going to use that argument to not feed
their baby well why feed that thing in 4
billion years the sun's going to develop
the Earth it's like wrong time frame
folks and so what I would say and I did
say to my clinical clients if if you're
adopting a time frame that makes what
you're doing appear trivial the problem
isn't necessarily what you're doing
although it might be and you have to ask
yourself that question because perhaps
you are engaging in something that's
more trivial than you should be the
problem is that your mind which is
capable of Leaping across evaluative
Frameworks has picked a time frame
inappropriate for the task so quit doing
that instead you could say well why
don't you practice adopting the time
frame that imbus your properly oriented
action with the deepest possible
apprehended meaning and why would you
not think that the fact that that
meaning manifests itself with the proper
choice of time frame why wouldn't you
accept the fact that's indication of a
valid Choice it certainly feels like it
you know what you know what it's like
you get engaged in something a deep
conversation a piece of music a piece of
art something you love doing someone you
love being with you get engaged in that
you lose your sense of temporality and
you don't pop out of it and think oh my
God I wish I would used the time frame
that made everything irrelevant because
of my you know cognitive Brilliance you
think hey we could do that some more
like how about all the time and that's
that's a good goal it's like yeah how
about that all the time and then you've
got time right when you're engaged like
that and I would say that's a profound
neurophysiological signal that you're in
the right place at the right time right
because it's accompanied by a sense of
deep well-being and that's literally an
antidote suffering I and I mean that
literally it's with many of my clients
who were
suffering what we would strive to do was
not so much make them happy because
sometimes that was impossible they were
so crippled in in so many ways often
physically and in pain but something
meaningful that would keep them going
and keep them from straying and keep
them from thinking homicidal and
genocidal thoughts all of that and
meaning that's the antidote to suffering
and the question is well how's that best
to be found well that's an empirical
question you have to you have to look in
your own life and see where meaning
glimmers and then pursue that right
that's what Harry Potter is doing by the
way when he's chasing the snitch just
thought I'd let you know and and you
know you win the game if you catch that
thing so well that's not exactly right
you get 100 points but you know it'll do
if you lose your
nature then you have no purpose outside
your own will you can't lose your nature
exactly you can lose your higher order
integrated purpose-driven nature here
are some Natures you won't lose pain
anxiety like you can lose your higher
nature all you want and all of the
negative elements of your nature will
predominate and you're not going to
rationalize yourself out of pain and
anxiety this is the thing about those
who believe life has no meaning it's
like I see so you think you can argue
yourself out of your pain because Pain's
a meaning now you might say well it's
not a meaning I want to pursue it's like
what does that have to do with anything
pain is an undeniable
reality well if you allow your higher
order self to disintegrate you dis you
disintegrate into a landscape
characterized by pain anxiety and
hopelessness that's the metaphysical
desert by the way right that's a place
you end up devolving into when your
tyrannical presuppositions are
disintegrate which is why people cling
to their tyrannical presuppositions
because you know there's a mystery well
you don't want to end up in the
landscape of pain anxiety and
hopelessness and I actually mean that
technically because what happens when
you lose direction the biological
systems that mediate negative emotion
signal loss of Direction that's What
anxiety is it's a signal of loss of
Direction so if you lose higher order
Direction you become anxious well and
you can argue with anxiety all you want
with your atheistic nihilism but it
isn't going to go away and neither is
your p pain and so one of the things
I've told my audiences
is you have to be a fool if you doubt
the reality of pain and anxiety pain and
Terror let's say are they real moving to
somewhere good that's a good thing but
getting the hell away from something
terrible that's also motivating and so
if you put that hell behind you and you
know the promised land in front of you
you're kind of maximally motivated to
move forward through obstacles and so so
you know we can't do any of this
casually it's it's not easy to stand up
for what you believe to be right in the
marketplace and the way to do that is to
mold yourself into someone who can do
that and there's nothing but there's
nothing but good in that it's difficult
but there's nothing but good in that and
almost all my clients when we went
through that process it often took two
years sometimes
longer
the invariable outcome was that they no
not
invariable there was aut time or two it
didn't work exactly that well most of
the time people went on to far better
jobs at far better salaries in a much
more motivating position and were better
for themselves and for their family but
it takes work you know like it's not
just a matter of a casual objection it
it's not good enough it's not
sophisticated enough free speech is not
a right among other
rights it's the predicate of All rights
it's also the predicate of a functioning
psyche I mean this I I don't mean this
politically I I mean it technically it's
the predicate of a functioning psyche
and it's the predicate of a society that
can maintain its integrity and its adap
to flexibility simultaneously and to say
that to say that is no different than
saying
that thought is the Bedrock of
adaptation now if I can speak freely I
can express my thoughts and so then you
might think erroneously that the reason
I have free speech is so that I have the
freedom to express my thoughts and
that's also not why I have freedom of
speech even though that's a Cory I have
freedom of
speech so that I can
think now the reason that works that is
it a technical definition and a truth is
because it's twofold one is you think in
words you think by internalizing
dialogue most people can't
think they think by talking you think
by putting forward your Viewpoint and
then having it opposed by someone else
and then you might say well why should
you put up with the opposition and the
answer is well what if you're stupid and
wrong
well and and the right response to that
is well I am stupid and wrong please
correct me and because the alternative
to being corrected in that way is
death really so here's how it works
biologically this makes human beings
unique by the way
so animals are much the same generation
to generation and if an
animal acts out a
conceptualization and the
conceptualization fails
dramatically then the
animal dies and that's the end of the
conceptualization and human
beings determined at some point in the
past to take a slightly alternative
route or a radically alternative
route the part of our brain that we use
to generate abstract thought is not a
part of the that generates abstract
factual representations of the world so
it's also not the case that you have
freedom of speech so that you can
discuss your facts about things in the
world that isn't how it works what the
way it works instead is that you use
your capacity for abstraction to produce
abstracted variants of
yourself they abstracted variants of the
next iteration of you you you might put
it that way that's what a thought is and
then you test the validity the viability
of that abstracted representation of You
by subjecting it to the criticisms that
are analogous to the opposition that
that would meet in the real world so the
reason that you call someone out on
their stupidity is so they don't run
headlong into a brick wall and that's
why you discipline your children it's
like you have to stop thinking that way
well why cuz you'll act that way well so
what I like to act that way it makes me
happy so that' be the hedonistic
response well if you act that way the
world will object perhaps the Natural
World perhaps the social world and you
will fail and that will be desperately
miserable and that will be much worse
than the small pain that you're going to
have to undergo if you just sacrifice
your stupidity now and so the really the
progressives might say you have no right
you have no right to hurt someone's
feelings and the answer is well you
should hurt their feelings if the
alternative is to let them die and
that's what you do that is exactly what
you do if you interfere with people's
ability to think not only do you let
them die you doom them to death because
their stupid ideas don't die and then
they do and the purpose of thinking the
purpose of thinking is to let your
stupid thoughts die instead of you the
past authoring you know there's a good
dictum from Clinical Psychology that
it's better to voluntarily face your
demons let's say or the dragons right
it's you you put yourself in the zone of
proximal development by adopting a a
voluntary stance of confrontation with
complexity and threat and one of the
things we ask people in the past
authoring exercise to do is to divide
their life into sections epochs and then
to write about the more emotionally
compell in experiences right both
negative and positive and yeah that's
quite difficult and it does upset people
I mean the research literature indicated
most of this generated by pennebaker and
his and the people who followed in his
footsteps basically showed that if you
do an autobiographical exercise like
that which is Akin in some sense to both
confession and to psychotherapy is that
the immediate consequences are negative
because reliving those upsetting
experiences is upsetting and can put you
into a bit of a spin but the medium to
long-term consequences are very positive
both on the performance and on the
mental and physical health front and so
you can think of self author all of
those of you who are watching and
listening you can think of this
selfauthoring.com set of exercises the
self-authoring suite as what would you
say as it's in some sense do it-yourself
well Redemption but certainly do it
yourself Psychotherapy and you know
maybe it couldn't substitute for
extremely high quality Psychotherapy
conducted by someone who really knows
what he or she is doing but it's a
pretty damn
good
home activity if you want to set your
life straight how do you think through
an idea well the first question is well
what bugs you what's bugging you this is
such a cool thing it's like where is my
destiny
well what bothers you well that's where
your destiny is your destiny is to be
found in what bothers you why do those
things bother you there's a lot of
things you could be bothered by like a
million things man but some things grip
you they bug you and they might make you
resentful and bitter because they bug
you so much like they're your things man
they've got you so then I look for a
question that I would like the answer to
that I don't and I would really like the
answer to it so I don't assume I already
have the answer cuz I would actually
really like to have the answer so if I
could get a better
answer great and so that's the first
thing and that's like a prayer it's like
okay here's a mystery I would like to
delve into it further well so that's
humility it's like here's a mystery
which means I don't know I would like to
delve into it further which means I
don't know enough already
and then then comes the Revelation it's
like well what's a revelation well if
you ask yourself a question it's a real
question do you get an answer or not the
answer is well yeah thoughts start to
appear in your head there's an interest
there in in children's stories then what
what where where does that interest for
you come from why have you focused on a
screen pray and two books and this this
poetry is clearly well you never know if
you're if you're pursuing something
creative you actually don't know why not
really because the creative Pursuit is
the discovery of why in some if you can
say exactly why you're doing an artistic
project you're probably producing
propaganda most of the time if you're
doing something creative you discover
why long after and if it's a work of
creative genius it might take
generations of people hundreds of years
to discover why you were doing it
because art really is on the Forefront
of C of transformation I mean literally
and
practically art especially imaginative
art but any true art it's it's not
philosophy yet right but it's also not
the unknown it's right on the border and
or that's where artists live the Open
People by temperament they live on the
border between Order and Chaos and
they're farther out into the chaos which
is why they often have chaotic lives and
often can't catalyze an identity right
because they're also one of the problems
with being creative and we're seeing
that a lot of the people who have
identity issues let's say in the modern
world um they may have their
psychological problems and that's
generally uh highly likely but they also
tend to be more creative and the
downside of creativity is that it's very
difficult to catalyze identity because
you're mutable if you're creative
because you're not by definition if
you're creative you're not the same
thing from moment to moment and you see
this in this insistence about the
mutability of identity well you know you
can be one gender one minute and another
the next it's like well yes in some
sense but what do what the hell do you
expect the people around you to do right
to keep up with your mutable
Transformations like good luck the first
thing that you might want to consider is
that the world is a very complicated
place now we've talked about this before
and the way that you handle there's way
too much complexity for you to handle in
its in its entirety so for example in a
room like this there's an endless number
of phenomena that you could focus your
attention on right from the sort of
macro phenomena which would be the
overall say color or appearance of the
room to the micro phenomena which would
be the details at the highest level of
detail that you're able to perceive that
litter the landscape anywhere and so one
of the problems that you have to solve
when you're operating in the world is
how you perceive the world and we do
that in part by making I would say that
we perceive low resolu ution
representations of the world and we also
confuse those with the world so when I'm
looking at you I'm really looking at a
low represent what I perceive
consciously is a low represent low
resolution representation of you right I
only see the front of you to begin with
I only see your surface
and in some sense you know I even
perceive you in some sense has a more or
less uniform color it's hard to tell
exactly what color skin is it's sort of
a light pink roughly speaking but my my
perception is fairly is fairly I don't
know a better way of putting it than low
resolution and I seem to perceive you at
the level of resolution that's that's
sufficient the the lowest resolution
that's sufficient to facilitate our
interactions because I don't want to
clutter up my perceptions of you when
we're just talking with excess detail so
there's lots of things about you I don't
need to see I certainly can't see any of
your micro structures below the below
the phenomenal level like I can't tell
without tremendous further investigation
What You're Made Of biologically for
example and I certainly can't perceive
the networks of society that you're
engaged in your family or the other
sorts of networks that you're embedded
in I see you here now the front of you
at low resolution and you can tell that
to some degree and we've talked about
this before because if you see say
animated movies that use very low
resolution representations of people
like South Park is a really good example
because the imit or the animation in
South Park's very
iconic and and and and simple it
actually makes almost no difference to
following the story and so that shows
you how iconic your perception really is
can be replaced by very simple icons and
you instantly adapt to that you know and
so we can go and see The Lego Movie
Batman Lego Movie for example and the
fact that it's Batman which is an
abstraction to begin with and then it's
made out of Legos is almost irrelevant
to following the plot and so some people
have compared our perceptions to the
user interface on a computer you know
when you're interacting with your
computer you don't really interact so to
speak with the computer there are iconic
representations on the screen of the
computer that you interact with and
those represent obviously they share
some functional relationship with what's
going on in the computer but mostly
they're there so that you using your
perceptual structures can interact with
the computer in a manner that's easy for
extremely intelligent Apes roughly
speaking now so one of the problems that
you have to solve in the world because
it's so full of detail and so complex is
how do you actually see the world how do
you actually perceive it and it isn't
really self-evident that that's a
problem because you think when you look
at the world that it just presents
itself to you but it's a tremendously
complicated problem and that's partly
why developing artificial intelligence
systems that can actually see the world
and act in it in any real way has proved
to be a much more difficult problem than
people had originally supposed because
you know we were told maybe from the
early 60s onwards that such things as
speech to text or object Rec recognition
or robots that could operate in the
world were only two or three years away
and well I mean we're in we're in a
situation now where there are some
fairly complicated robots built but
they're still really in their nent form
and it's because perceiving the world
and then figur out how to act and it
turns out to be a much more complicated
problem than we originally thought
because the borders between things are
not self-evident and what level of
resolution you should be perceiving
things at for say maximal functional
utility is also not self-evident it's
also tied up very strangely and in ways
we don't understand with the nature of
your embodiment you know so for example
we tend to see see things that are handy
because we can pick them up and
manipulate them and we can make use of
them and so to some degree our brains
are evolved to make the world manifest
itself to us in a set of discreet usable
tools that's that's a reasonable way of
thinking about it and they're discreet
usable because we have a certain kind of
biological platform you know because we
have hands and mouths and because we
walk in a bipedal manner then it's
logical for us to break up the world in
a manner that makes operating in this
body maximally useful but that doesn't
mean that there's a straightforward
one-to-one relationship between our
perceptions of things and the things
themselves quite the contrary and that's
partly of course we know that because
with any perceptible object like I could
conceptualize you as one thing for all
sorts of purposes but if I'm trying to
solve a complex problem in relationship
to you it's going to be very difficult
to determine how to conceptualize you so
if I'm if you come to me because you're
suffering from a psychological problem
of some sort then I have to figure out
you know is it organic is it is it
there's actually something physiological
wrong with you and I need to know what
level of analysis I would probably
conceptualize you at is it psychological
is it and if it's psychological is it
functional like do you lack the skills
or do you lack the ability to apply the
skills or is there something really gone
wrong with your family or maybe it's
even a reflection of an overarching
sociological problem we know for example
that when the unemployment rate goes up
1% psychiatric hospitalizations go up
5% and so then you might ask well you
know if you're if there's a huge rise in
depression and anxiety across the
population and at the same time there's
a huge increase in in unemployment you
have to ask yourself what level of
perception would best be suited to solve
that problem because it isn't
self-evident that it's psychological at
the level of the individual anyways my
point is is that perception is a very
difficult problem you're probably not
particularly well suited for jobs that
require a tremendous amount of
transformation of thinking or a
tremendous amount of abstraction but
that doesn't mean there are no jobs for
you and so jobs that are more stable and
repetitive routine let's say you're
better suited for
vocational jobs and there's vocational
jobs play an remarkably important role
in our
culture so and hard work could get you a
long ways and so you know I don't know
what you mean when you say low
intelligence you know I mean there are
catastrophically low
intelligence ratings say 60 and below
it's tough to find anything that you're
going to be able to be productive in
doing and I don't know what to do about
that above that hard work is going to
make a huge difference and aiming right
so aim at the vocation end of the
distribution and put a plan in place and
stick to it and work diligently at it
that's what you've got you've got your
ability to work and maybe you can
capitalize on your other personality
attributes as well and as I've said
already in this podcast you can do a
personality tested understand.com I
would also say on my selfauthoring.com
website There's an opportunity for you
to map out a
plan and this one of the to map out a
plan to write about your past but also
to write about your present self so the
present authoring program enables you to
do an inventory of your personality
strengths and weaknesses and there's a
virtues analysis and a faults analysis
and I would say if you're leery about
your future for whatever reason you
should do the virtues analysis it's like
what have you got to offer and hopefully
you have the ability to work hard and
maybe you have other personality
attributes that are important and that
you could understand and then capitalize
on so I would say do the understand.com
personality test do the virtues section
of the present authoring exercise at
selfauthoring.com put together a plan
and aim at the vocational end of the job
distribution don't despair there's
plenty of opportunity at that level for
someone who's honest which is a huge
Advantage who has Integrity who's
willing to work
hard I'm not going to sugarcoat it you
know life is harder at the shallow end
of the Jean Pool let's say to use scars
phrase from The Lion King we're all at
the shallow end of the Jean Pool in some
regard you know know
so the cognitive end is that's a rough
hit but General cognitive ability isn't
everything even though it's a lot of
things and so aim Integrity hard work a
plan that's what you've got and so you
have to make the best of it it's a
mistake to be fatally cynical about
politics
because for all the reasons there are be
fatally cynical about politics there's
much more reason to be fatally cynical
about the conflict that will inevitably
arise or the Tyranny that will
inevitably manifest itself if we can't
handle the dirty business of politics
properly so I would say don't become
prematurely cynical about it the next
thing I would say
is what do you
know and that that's a very important
question it's like what does it mean to
get into politics exactly does that mean
to seek political power does that mean
to seek power well first of all you
shouldn't be seeking power you should be
seeking
competence and in order to seek
competence you better know something and
so I would say well if you want to get
into politics you want to educate
yourself you know in in all the things
you need to be educated in life I mean
you can you can start to play the
political game to familiarize yourself
with it but you know it's not such a bad
idea to well it's not such a bad idea to
have a job for a while and and maybe a
career and maybe it's not such a bad
idea to have a successful career upon in
which people are dependent on you so
that you start to understand what that
sort of responsibility means and then
maybe it's not such a bad idea to have a
family because like human beings mature
adult human beings tend to have families
and and they transform when they have
families because when you have children
then someone becomes more important to
you than you are and you're not mature
until that happens and so that's
necessary and so I would say well make
sure that if you're looking to get into
politics that you're even more looking
to get into competence and that you
learn everything you can possibly learn
that would make you a reasonably wise
person by the time you attain what
whatever level of power you might
Authority let's say you might be seeking
I mean I've seen lots of people get into
politics you know this happens with
ideologues and the way they ratchet
themselves up the power hierarchy is by
being more effective avatars puppets of
their particular ideological stance and
there's nothing about that that's useful
there's nothing in it that will solve
any real world problems and there's
plenty that will make it much worse and
so if that's what getting into politics
means I would say stay the hell away
from it but if it's a matter of
developing your character and then at
some point adopting your social
responsibility then go for it and more
power to you because we need people who
are competent and careful and truthful
and courageous and forthright to enter
the political sphere so that things
don't degenerate and hopefully have some
chance of at least maintaining
themselves or improving so there's
you need what do you need to know you
you need to be really good at at least
one thing you have to specialize you
have to be a great networker you have to
know a lot of people you have to be
honest you have to be articulate you
have to you have to have a vision you
have to have a strategy you have to know
something about history and economics
and politics be good to know something
about science you know you have to be a
polymath of sorts before you should dare
to enter that realm with any degree of
confidence because otherwise all you are
as a Loose Cannon and you'll come up
with global proposals to improve improve
the world you know by waving your wand
that will do nothing but make everything
worse physical attractiveness is a very
complex trait um it's also for example
it's a marker of health and of course
health is a mar is a prerequisite for
Success so um I you can't take
attractiveness as a unitary Dimension
and measure it sufficiently
accurately wait I should back up on that
no one that I know of has taken physical
attractiveness as a unitary concept
measured it accurately and then pitted
it against IQ and the big five to see if
it to what degree it adds incremental
validity to the prediction of long-term
success but physical but and so I can't
give you a technical answer you know I
can say well in a complex job over the
long run IQ accounts for maybe 20% of
the variance in success leaving 80%
there for random events and and the big
five traits and connection networks and
and family background and all those
other things gender perhaps that all the
other things that determine success
physical we know that physical that
people who are physically attractive
though are given the benefit of Doubt by
other people they they benefit from the
positive halo effect and the positive
halo effect is the propensity of people
to assume good things about someone if
there is one outstanding thing about
them that easily evident that's good and
so if you're if you're if you stand up
straight with your shoulders back so
that's rule one and 12 rules for life
then people are going to see you as more
attractive if you're symmetrical you're
more attractive if you're thin but not
too thin you're more attractive
um well and then there's like good skin
and good teeth and good hair and and all
of those things in proper proportions
and youth and there's a whole slew of
things that that that feed into that if
you are characterized by a plethora of
those features then people are also
going to assume that you're more
competent and more um and more more
worth having around let's say but the
problem is is that you are so separating
out the attractiveness from the things
the attractiveness are is correlated
with is very hard that's why you have to
do multivariate analysis that's
multivariable analysis in any complex
social science because a lot of these
traits overlap so but you know you can
you can there's there's some some things
you can do about that postural
adjustment is helpful to work out with
weights that's extraordinarily helpful
that that increases improves your
posture and makes you more confident and
and and and and at and you can dress
reasonably well and intelligently and um
all of those things to to help yourself
capitalize on whatever attractiveness
you can muster young people always have
a reason to be upset and cynical about
the current state of affairs and and
it's that way forever and and so it's
useful I think to consider such
considerations or such
conceptualizations as the of the as the
patriarchy in that light because it's an
archetypal truth that the social
structure is corrupt and incomplete and
and what that means is that it's
something that you have to contend with
every moment in some sense of your life
it's a it's a permanent fact of
existence and to be upset that the
structures the social structures or even
the biological structures within which
we live are incomplete and
imperfect is to and to take that
personally that that's the worst part of
it to take that personal personally is a
misreading of the existential condition
of humankind because it's always the
case that what you have been given and
and what you live in is degenerate and
corrupt and in need of
repair and it's easier to just to accept
that because there's also a positive
element and the positive element is well
you you've been granted something rather
than
nothing and maybe you haven't been
granted pure hell because especially in
a culture like ours where many things
actually function quite well so there's
room for gratitude there even if it's a
broken machine it's not one that's
completely devastated and it's not
absolutely hellbent at every second on
your misery and destruction and it
easily could be because many societies
are like that and so the fact that we
happen to live in one that isn't corrupt
Beyond imagining is something to be
eternally grateful for Canada had a good
run the United States had a good run but
sustaining free societies across the
decades and across the generations is
just too hard for human nature to
bear no you're not supposed to agree
with that well two two things you know
the first thing is that man does not
live by bread alone so so that's the
first rejoinder and the second
is with regards to difficulty well the
only thing more difficult than
contending forthrightly with existence
is failing to do so I'm I'm not
suggesting for a moment that this isn't
difficult I mean part of the what the
Western religious tradition has done and
religious traditions in general to some
degree is to try to provide people with
support from what's Divine in their
incalculably difficult efforts to deal
with the unknown let's say the
unknowable know that if you Orient
yourself ethically in the most
fundamental sense then in some sense you
have the force of God on your side and
then maybe you can Prevail despite the
difficulty and I think that's I think
that's right I I I think it's I think
that's true so and you can ask
yourself I try to ask these questions
seriously you know and I would also say
that I've been driven to my religious
belief such as it is by necessity not by
desire um what do you want to have on
your side when you're contending with
the unknowable future and its vagaries
uh how about truth how about beauty how
about Justice you want allies those are
powerful allies that's what the
university is supposed to be teaching
young people it's like you need some
allies man well how about the pursuit of
Truth well then the scientists have
their say and I would say on economic
front well how about the free trade
between autonomous individuals the free
trade of goods of value between
autonomous individuals that's not such a
bad thing to have on your side these
Eternal varities and then we could say
perhaps that well there is a set of
Eternal varities but they're all Eternal
Vari so they share something in common
some good in common all good things
share some good in common well what is
the good that they share in common well
for all intents and
purposes that's God
and you might say well I don't believe
in that it's like well I don't know what
you mean you don't believe there's any
such thing as good you don't believe
there's any such thing as ultimate good
I'm not trying to make some ontological
Claim about an old man living in the sky
although I think that's a lot more
sophisticated concept than people
generally realize that's not my point my
point is you do have a belief system
whether you know it or not it's a system
of Ethics whether you know it or not
there's either something at the bottom
that unifies it or it's not Unified
which means you're aimless and hopeless
and depressed and anxious and confused
because those are the only other options
and maybe you don't know what that
unifying belief is but that doesn't mean
that it's not there it just means you
don't know what it is and so I'm trying
to puzzle out what it is you know I've I
can give you a couple of examples very
very briefly because I won't so I I
already mentioned the Genesis the story
in Genesis it Associates god with the
the force process that generates
habitable order out of chaos and
attributes that nature in some sense to
human beings um in the next part of the
story in the story of Adam and Eve um
God is what people walk with
unselfconsciously in the garden So Adam
doesn't because he's now ashamed and he
doesn't walk with God anymore but so
what is god well that's what you walk
with when you're unselfconscious so
that's an interesting idea and then you
have the god that manifests itself
himself let's say in the story of Noah
and that's the that's the intuition that
hard times are coming and that you
better get your house in order and you
think well does that lead you that
intuition well certainly sometimes if
you have any sense it's like well what's
the nature of the intuition is that a
spirit that animates you well obviously
because there you are acting and so
you're acting out a pattern it's a
spirit that animates you and so and then
there's the story of the Tower of Babel
what's God there well God is that which
you replace at your peril because
everything will come tumbling down
that's the Tower of Babel it's like well
is that true or not you think about that
for a week especially in that light you
think oh definitely if we put the wrong
thing at the top like Stalin for example
then look out and we've done that a
bunch of times in the 20th century I
think you know
Milton conceptualized Lucifer as
something like this Spirit of unbridled
intellectual arrogance it's something
like Lucifer is the lightbringer and he
is engaged in a conflict with God
attempting to replace the Divine and
that's pretty explicit in the story and
I look at that and I think oh that's a
poetic intuition of the of the battle
between secular the secular intelligence
IA and the religious structure that's
Milton's PR droma and what he sees
happening is the intellect has become so
arrogant that it will attempt to replace
the Divine and rule over hell I think
yeah well that's the Soviet Union man
that's maest China we know we know we've
got our Theory it's
total we've solved the problem and
nothing's going to change fair enough if
you want to rule over hell and you think
well these societies are successful it's
pretty odd definition of su uccess as
far as I'm concerned you want to be
successful like China you know that's
why it's true that man does not live by
bread alone you know a wealthy slave
that's no life man in this time of
conflict around culture how can people
come together to oppose real power real
corrupt power at the level of the state
and the corporation to make them
accountable and to create new models and
systems well I think that one of the
things that's happened is that people
Ordinary People let's say have not
fulfilled their civic responsibility in
the proper manner so what's I think
what's happening Russell is that we're
transforming our society into a literal
Tower of Babel and so a Tower of Babel
is a an abstract Enterprise designed to
replace God to reach to the Heavens to
become totalitarian and its fundamental
nature is the aggregation of power and
resp responsibility at the top and the
atomization of the citizenry and that
happens when the citizens abandon their
intermediary
responsibilities and so in this seminar
in Exodus that I just conducted we
talked about the principle of
subsidiarity now this is what happens in
Exodus and it's it's very much worth
delving into briefly if we can do that
so Moses leads these slaves out of
Israel and everyone in the modern world
thinks that's a hell of a good idea
because you shouldn't be a slave and you
shouldn't be a tyrant and so we could
think of that as a self-evident axom in
some sense you should be free so you
have to remove yourself from the tyranny
of your own imagination and you have to
remove yourself from the tyranny of
State actors but the problem is when you
remove yourself from tyranny is you
don't get to the promised land you go to
the
desert and that's because everything
falls apart around you when you drop
your tyrannical
presuppositions and so then you're lost
and aimless and fraction ated and so
that's the situation that confronts
Moses when he leads his people into the
desert they're not free they're now
they're in the desert they're just
wandering aimlessly and that's the
position we're in right now now what
happens is that because the Israelites
have no tradition of freedom and no
internal order they start fighting
amongst themselves and that's also what
happens in the Tower of Babel when
people are too fractionated they become
unable to communicate and they all start
speaking a different language and that's
certainly happening at the moment and so
Moses sets himself up as judge to
adjudicate all the conflicts that the
Israelites find themselves embroiled in
in the desert and so now he's sitting
from dawn until midnight every day doing
nothing but listening to people fighting
and he does this for
years and then his BR his father-in-law
comes along he's a midianite priest so
he's the archetype of the ethical
Outsider a very common kind of character
in in the Old and New Testaments like
the Good Samaritan and Jethro comes to
Moses and he says 'look man you got to
stop doing this and Moses says why
essentially and Jethro says look there's
two reasons first of all you're wearing
yourself to a frazzle nobody can take on
that much responsibility and live and
second you're denying the Israelites
their Destiny and you're and basically
you're setting yourself up as an
alternative pho in the desert by taking
all the responsibility onto yourself and
so then he says well they decide well
what what should we do as an alternative
so this is the question is what's the
alternative to tyranny and slavery and
Jethro tells Moses divide the Israelites
into groups of 10 and have each of the
10 nominate a leader and then group the
leaders together and have them nominate
leader and make a an intermediary
hierarchy up to tens of thousands and
then allow them to adjudicate their own
disputes at the most local level
possible and any disputes that can't be
intermediated at those local levels that
eventually trickle up to you you can
decide and so this is a hierarchy of
responsibility as an alternative to
slavery and tyranny and it's also the
model for
the it's the model for the uh for the
later establishment of religious
institutions and so what do people have
to do they have to find a mate they have
to get married they have to have a
family they have to engage in Civic
activity they have to sit on their
school boards they have to run for local
office they have to join a business
organization they have to join a
political party they because imagine
this every bit of social responsibility
you abdicate will be vacuumed up by a
narcissistic
Tyrant that's what will happen that's
what will happen those people are just
waiting for that responsibility to be
transferred into their power take on
some
responsibility do something for other
people you're doing something for
yourself while you're doing that even if
you don't know it for sure because
you're a community across time find
something to serve somebody to help to
solve a job to find a job do your best
with the customers don't be above your
job you're going to get an entry-level
job when you're a kid well what else
would you want you want to be the boss
what do you know you don't know anything
you could be the boss of your job you
know if you're working in a grocery
store or you're working in a convenience
store assuming you're not working for
terrified
tyrants you can be nice to the customers
you can develop your social skills you
can learn how to handle boss employee
relationship you can be there 15 minutes
early and leave 15 minutes late like you
can learn in an entry-level job man and
I'll tell you if you take an entry-level
job and you learn and it's a reasonably
decent place you will not be in an
entry-level job for long because
everyone who's competent is desperate
for competent people and if you go and
show yourself as competent there'll be a
trial period but if you go show yourself
as competent all sorts of doors you
didn't even know were there will start
opening like mad see strive for
competence for craftsmanship y y I've
been really fortunate over the last six
years because I've had a group of a
family members and friends around me who
have their own independent viewpoints
and who want nothing from me who
constantly are interacting with me and
making sure that I'm not you know
wandering off the path and some manner
that's untoward you know and there's
been some pretty intense discussions
about that at multiple times but it is
very useful to have people around you
who you know who you talk through your
strategy the one you just laid out and
say look guys I'd like you to keep an
eye on me and if you think I'm striking
some false notes or I'm starting to be
you know the great Wonderful Oz the
projection of the leader that you know
you can rein me in a bit and you know if
you do put that goal to keep control of
your tongue first and foremost in mind
then and then you have people who can
reflect that back to you you know you
can stay on the proper track you might
ask why I would be concerned with
bringing the history of the Bible to a
more popular
audience we inevitably and must see the
world through the lens of a
story a story is a description of the
implicit structure through which we View
the world and prioritize our perceptions
and determine how to act now because you
can act in a very large variety of ways
that plethora of possibility has to be
limited and focused it has to come to a
point it has to have a destination it
has to have a moral it has to have an
ethic and what a story is is a
description of an ethic of attentional
and action
prioritization peace is dependent upon
us being brought together under the
rubric of a single centralizing
narrative much of which is reflected in
The Meta narrative that the biblical
Library
constitutes do you have advice for
people on how to find a way
out you're a man who has suffered in
this way perhaps continue to suffer in
this way how do you find a way out the
first thing I do as a clinician if
someone comes to me and says they're
depressed is ask myself a
question well what does this person mean
by that so I have to find out like
because maybe they're not depressed
maybe they're hyper anxious or maybe
they're obsessional like there's various
forms of powerful negative emotion so
they need to be differentiated but then
the next question you have to ask is
well are you depressed or do you have a
terrible life or is it some combination
of the two so if you're
depressed as far as I can tell you don't
have a terrible
life you have friends you have family
you have an intimate relationship you
have a job or a career you're about as
educated as you should be given your
intelligence use your time outside of
work wisely you're not beholden to
alcohol or other
Temptations um you're engaged in the
community in some fundamental sense and
all that's working now if you have all
that and you're feeling really awful
you're either ill or you're depressed
and and so then sometimes there's a
biochemical route to that treatment of
that my experience has been as a
clinician is if you're depressed but you
have a life and you take an
anti-depressant it will probably help
you a lot now maybe you're not depressed
exactly you just have a terrible life
what does that look
like you have no relationship your
family's a mess you've got no friends
You' got no plan you've got no job you
use your time outside of work not only
badly but destructively you have a drug
or alcohol H habit or some other Vice
pornography addiction um you are
completely unengaged in the surrounded
Community you have no scaffolding
whatsoever to support you in your
current mode of being or you move
forward and then as a therapist well you
do two things well if it's depression
per se well like I said there's
sometimes a biochemical route a
nutritional route there's ways that can
be addressed it's probably physiological
if you're at least in part if you're
depressed but you have an okay life
sometimes it's conceptual you can turn
to dreams sometimes to help people
because dreams contain the seeds of the
potential future and if your person is a
real good dreamer and you can analyze
dreams that can be really helpful but
that seems to be only true for more
creative people and for the people who
just have a terrible life it's like okay
you have a terrible life
well let's pick a front how about you
need how about you need a friend like
one sort of friend do you know how to
shake hands and introduce yourself I'll
have the person show me so let's do it
for a sec
so it's like this hi I'm Jordan right
and people don't know how to do that and
then they can't even get the ball
rolling what makes Jordan happy and when
was the LA last time you had the longest
stretch of Happiness what caused it
those two questions I'm
curious oh I had a lot of happiness I
would say when I was on tour okay uh it
was unbelievably exciting I had some
health problems during that period of
time too so there was a shadow there but
that made me happy on a continual basis
it was unbelievably exciting and
engaging I mean people are happy when
they're pursuing something that they
find meaningful deeply meaningful
especially when that's going well on in
a day-to-day level
I find most of my happiness I would say
um well in engaging conversation that's
for sure but also with my family and you
know that's partly why I said what I did
say when in that clip that you showed
earlier you know what's makes me most
happy right now is when my family gets
together so that's my immediate family
my wife my kids and their and their
spouses and there's no uh uh there's
nothing buried underneath the rugs and
everyone's joking and laughing and
playing and that's and it's peaceful
it's truly peaceful and that does happen
I go to see my son quite often he lives
just up the street from me uh
fortunately enough and I really like his
wife and her Jillian is her name and
Jillian and my My Wife Tammy have really
tried to make their relationship to
perfect their relationship to get rid of
any you know of the cliched
Mother-in-law daughter-in-law trouble
and some that was there to begin with
and they both decided and I suppose we
all decided consciously as a unit that
we're going to get rid of all of that
and just stop it and try to have a
really good relationship and that really
worked and so now I go over there and
it's they're happy they're smiling it's
they're it's peaceful there their their
little boy is laughing he's playing with
laughing and so we had some people over
for Easter dinner my son and and his
wife and a couple of friends of theirs
and they had a little baby named
Florence and she was also the same agent
she was playing with laughing so she
would go ha and then this little my
grandson Elliot would go and then all
the adults would laugh because these two
infants were actually having a
conversation with each other a Proto
conversation with laughter that lasted
for about 10 minutes and everyone was
laughing about it and well that there
isn't anything better than that when
there isn't all sorts of horror hidden
underneath the carpets you know in this
new book order I have a chapter called
don't hide things in the fog and it's
about this it's like wonderful things
can happen if you straighten out
everything that's hidden in a family and
and get it out in the open and um and
then you you have the opportunity then
for some real peace and some real joy
and certainly that's at the moment where
it's in those interpersonal interactions
that I derive a lot of my happiness and
that's been life-saving and then of
course the this active engaged
intellectual
conversation the sort of conversation
that we're doing our best to have that's
also and the fact that I can share that
with so many people and the the
responses are so positive it's wonderful
it's amazing I can't believe it I was
watching this movie King Arthur by Guy
Richie and when when the new king young
King Arthur takes his sword he has
flashbacks to his evil Uncle killing his
father and it just it's so terrible that
he can't hold on to the sword and I
thought well it's Richie doing there
it's well that's the case for all of us
isn't it because when we look into the
past and we see our evil
uncles it's just a complete bloody
catastrophic mess isn't it slavery and
genocide and War and oppression and like
and that's on all of us isn't it and
it's always lurking there in the
background and so is that male power
well yes in some ways I mean if you
don't give a man a sword he can't use a
sword right so not giving him a sword is
one way of making sure he's peaceful but
it's not the it's not the optimal way
and besides if you men they
become far more dangerous they become
dangerous in an un terrible underground
fashion of course the same is exactly
true if you women but we're
speaking particularly of boys because I
suppose there's an education crisis
among boys and young men well you want
to encourage that power because it's
actually a tremendous Force for good if
it's brought under control
and so but that's a hard thing to get
right and it also requires a lot of
trust and work on the part of women
because they want to it's like Beauty in
the Beast right because beauty entices
that Beast who's a real who's real but
uncivilized and dangerous she sort of
entices him into becoming fully
developed and that's what a woman has to
do when she you know has that work
project that she marries or has a
long-term relationship with
but it's much better to encourage with
with faith and trust I continually ask
my frequently let's say or yearly asked
my personality class
attendees if they heard the voice of
conscience if they had a feeling an
emotion emotional state let's say or a
voice that informed them when they had
done something ethically wrong and that
perhaps made them guilty as a quence and
it was essentially a universal
experience and that's the voice of
society within I suppose that's one way
of thinking about it the freudians would
think about that as the voice of the
super eagle Yung Carl Yung would take
that conceptualization somewhat farther
he would have considered it the voice of
the self which is in part the voice of
the ethic that's derived from the
broader community in so far as that
ethic is valid let's say but also in
part the voice of the more thoroughly
developed self that's still striving to
be born one thing you could say is that
you you experience violations of your
conscience when you're not acting like
the better person that you could
possibly become and so to some degree
that's your higher self upgrading for
failure to develop in the appropriate
Direction and that seems to me to be a
reasonable way of conceptualizing it now
the one question might be how error
prone is your conscience given that
you're not omniscient
and I have an endless fascination with
the movie Pinocchio uh and part of that
is because it taught me something very
sophisticated about conscience in that
movie jimy Cricut is given Divine
attributes he has the same initials as
Jesus Christ for example and
um he is deemed the voice of conscience
Itself by by the magical properties of
of Mother Nature essentially but in the
movie it's necessary for the puppet
who's still wooden headed and still a
marionette whose strings are being
pulled by others it's necessary for the
puppet to engage in a dialogue with his
conscience because both of them have to
inform the other and that seems to me
approximately right because I certainly
saw people in my clinical practice and
know people in my private life who seem
to labor under a too
authoritarian labor under the dictates
of a two
authoritarian
conscience U maybe that's the internal
ized voice of a relatively tyrannical
father for example um or you know
exaggerated sensitivity to the moral
pressure exerted by the broader social
world you have
to attend to
your guilt and your self-disgust and
your self-contempt and your
self-consciousness you have
to understand that the manifestation of
those emotions might well indicate a
moral failing on your part or a
a a a lack that needs to be addressed
well at the same time considering that
it is not a
straightforward matter to deal fairly
with yourself and you can be too
tormented by your conscience too rigid
too
responsible take on too much weight onto
yourself
deny yourself in a manner that isn't
sustainable and so forth that that a
moral code a moral way of being can
become too rigid and and inflexible and
despite its putative aim
upward be something
counterproductive I think most of the
way out of that if there is one
is well careful thinking
you have to see what your conscience
says you have to see how you respond you
have to
capture that voice and your responses
and you have to think it through but
most of that is done in dialogue with
other people rather than as the
consequence of internal
thought you know if you have a dispute
with your wife or your husband your
intimate partner sibling your parents
anybody close to
you and it's useful to for each of you
in the dispute
to ask yourself and the other person
very
seriously if you're at fault or if
they're at fault and and for both of you
to be able to
contemplate that you might be at fault
and so might the other person and that
it's in your best interest to sort out
exactly who's made the error and where
and maybe it's both of you and maybe at
different levels of
analysis um I think the same might be
said about your reaction to your
conscience it's not uncommon for me to
talk to my wife my kids my
parents my friends for that matter about
something I might be feeling maybe I'm
guilty about something I'm
self-conscious about something I'm angry
about something um I feel impelled by my
conscience to do something as a
consequence to change
something uh it's very helpful to
discuss such things with other people to
say look
here's what I think I did wrong and
here's how I'm punishing myself but I'm
not sure that I'm not doing it in an
exaggerated way and you gather other
people's opinions and listen to them
carefully and friends are
extraordinarily useful in that regard
and that can help you calibrate
it so I think most of what we do to
decide if our inner voice is healthy is
discuss it with other people and I
believe as I pointed out in my last book
uh in explicitly that tremendous amount
of our sanity is maintained as a
consequence of social
interaction
so you can't find your authentic self
merely as a consequence of a journey
within I would say you you you're not
there's just not enough of you you you
have to be informed by the broader
social world because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some incredible Tony Robbins
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there life is both sugar and strict KN
so you better watch your coffee stand
guard at the door of your mind and the
way you used to say that is every day
take 30 minutes of your day and read not
that comes to you today not the
clickbait where you pick up a book